der knerbe er ist auch am start
twitch sagt mir ich hab wohl endlich channelpunkte
aber nur vor dem eigenen channel das ist ja next level und ich kann damit nix machen
oder bescheuert easy
genau der eichle so siehts aus und ich muss unbedingt Leute
muss ich mir die black mesa accent levels angucken
gut gegessen die tag also gestern gab's wild
weiß nicht ob re oder hirsch aber es war wild
ich glaube es war hirsch
wie schmeckt man da überhaupt einen unterschied
zwischen hirsch und re
mann warum ist es hirsch und re warum ist es nicht hirschinnen
man weiß es nicht
gestern gab es aber heiligabend gab es burger
ernsthaft
heiligabend gab es burger
da gab es mittags
warte ich muss mal kurz gucken
es reibt hier am mikrofon
heiligabend gab es burger
mittags gab es was ordentliches
abends gab es burger
ich hatte immer das problem auch heiligabend dass man sich so voll gestopft hat
dass man im prinzip den ganzen tag nix macht
also den restlichen tag nix mehr machen kann
slent
also mit was fangen wir an
diese 10 spiele muss man 2019 gespielt haben
na ich weiß nicht
das ist zu hoch koste das kann ich auch mal nicht angucken
selbst gebaute grafiker das ist zu anstrengend
high quality battlefield clips
die besten spiele für xbox one
das würde mich echt mal interessieren
weil ich habe die xbox one seit release
und hab ja das gucken wir jetzt nicht
oder vielleicht auch mal
ich hab die xbox one ja seit release
und ich hatte die vielleicht keine ahnung
2 stunden lang oder 5 stunden lang oder so
gar nicht eigentlich
voll sind total sinnlos
steam winter sale empfehlung können wir uns mal angucken
das hat spieler 2019 richtig hüten gemacht
na dann
was ist das denn
gta rtx
und video kann man mal gucken
also wo man halt das gut daran erkennt
ist die die der lichteinfall so auf wenden und so
auch vom schandler ich meine es sieht schon gut aus
für den game von von wann ist gta 2012 oder so
es ist ja auch schon gta 5 ist ja schon uralt eigentlich
packen wir die high quality gifs aus
ich muss mal mein video hier raus poppen
sonst finde ich nachher die musik streams nicht
so
gucken wir uns mal das gta video an ob das wirklich
so geil rtx on aussieht
ich meine
wie gesagt man darf nicht in 2013
aber es hat sich eh wenig getan die letzten jahre
dank amd wird das wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr
hoffe ich mal
zumindest dpu mäßig hat amd da viel bewirkt was kern
kernanzahl angeht
immer gut aussehen tut er schon kann man nichts sagen ja
ist das denn jetzt auch rtx on ja
ich meine für den sieben jahre
ja fast sieben jahre altes game
kann sagen es ist zu übertrieben aber es ist fast sieben jahre altes game
wenn es 2013 rausgekommen ist
wir haben fast 2020
ich meine für ein sieben jahre altes game sieht das doch echt nicht übel aus
ja
ich meine das könnte hier auch eine battlefield 5 landschaft sein
es ist eigentlich kein großer unterschied auf dem ersten blick
ich meine die haben das wahrscheinlich ultra gemodet
ob das jetzt 8k oder 4k ist es erstmal vollkommen egal
ich glaube das würden wir im video jetzt nicht den großartigen unterschied sehen
aber so von der landschaft her sieht das sieht das doch schon ganz ok aus
also die müssten mal
okay halt blör blör ist halt sack oder wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich blört es noch gar nicht mal so
wahrscheinlich hat er einfach nur 20 fps oder so
es könnte es könnte so eine so eine battlefield hardline
maps sein
ja blör ist das erste was ich in games mache ist immer blör ausstellen
blör aus bewegungs blör also bewegungs blör aus tiefen blör aus
umgebungs blör aus irgendwelche alles alles blör aus
maps und field auch aus wie so alles aus
und am besten wenn die fps nicht hoch genug sind
am besten erstmal fps details auf low und gucken wieviel maximal geht
aber für ein 7 jahre altes game muss man echt sagen
haben sie natürlich auch ein bisschen getunt ist klar
also das game
auto bestimmt auch
aber dafür sieht es wirklich ok aus
ja also das ist echt nicht nicht übel
vor allem muss man sagen im vergleich zu
witcher 3 nvidia witcher 3 demo mit rtx on
läuft es anscheinend ein bisschen mehr als als 15 fps
gut man muss aber auch ich finde generell
auto also gta jetzt nicht in gta kann man nur raussteigen rumlaufen
aber generell sind autorennspieler halt auch dankbar was grafik angeht
bei gta sieht es komplett anders aus aber autorennspieler an sich sind halt sehr dankbar
was grafik angeht
also was man da machen kann
deswegen war es nicht umsonst so zumindest zumindest früher letzten jahren ein bisschen
weniger
das heißt es ist ja auch nicht so dass autorennen spiele jetzt noch so eine große hype sind
dass eine ganze zeit lang auch auto
oder generell rennspiele so grafisch so vorne vorne mit dabei waren
es ist jetzt irgendwie ein channel der red dead redemption 2 5 max ultra settings
da bin ich mal gespannt wie das aussieht
es ist zwar der gta workshop aber gut
oder sieht gut aus also das mehr sieht richtig gut aus wobei
ich euch ehrlich sagen muss ich habe das original gar nicht gespielt
ich habe keine ahnung wieviel von dem mehr original original ist und wieviel von dem
mehr rtx ist
aber das ruckelt ein bisschen oh das ruckelt das ruckelt
es ruckelt
so mit dem hin und her gemovt könnte irgendwie assassins creed sein
wobei neben assassins creed wäre sie da jetzt drüber gejumpt
und alle hätten sie im hintergrund irgendwie gesagt
ho assassino ho
das war ja so gefühlt in assassins creed 2 war das das einzige voice sample was die
was die npcs hatten
die haben dann irgendwie gesagt so ho was ist hier los ho er muss verrückt sein assassino
assassino
wer konnte den nicht sagen
schreckt
es wäre natürlich cool wenn er ein bisschen irgendwie so ein bisschen mehr landschaft
mäßig zeigen würde weil
so von der bodentextur erkennt man jetzt nicht so geil
ja gibt es da auch irgendwo noch ein bisschen jetzt ein bisschen umgebung
oh das ruckelt das ruckelt
das ist so wie die witcher 3 laufdemo mit rtx on
wo er mit 5 fps gelaufen ist
ich mein gerade mal so muss man echt sagen
landschaftsmäßig sieht das wirklich gut aus
wenn man jetzt nicht wüsste
dass es ein game ist
und man würde sagen mal so hier erkennt man es halt direkt dran
also an dem ganzen ballon und an dem an dem model und an dem charakter
und so erkennt man es aber
beangenehm man würde das am zauen erkennt man das auch ein bisschen
ja der zauen sieht nicht so wirklich natürlich aus
aber beangenehm man würde das hier so ausschneiden
bisschen weiter weg hier vorne erkennt man es auch
beangenehm man würde es hier so ausschneiden
so direkt auf den ersten blick ersichtlich
ob das jetzt in game grafik oder foto ist
ist nicht
wäre nicht
wenn man wirklich nur in die ecke
wenn man hier so die ecke sehen würde
wobei man halt auch sagen muss wenn man sich die landschaft beispielsweise von witcher
3 anguckt
die sieht schon ähnlich gut aus
also wo wir wieder dabei sind dass sich da so viel gar nicht getan hat
die letzten jahre
ich mein gut sieht das schon aus
die witcher bäume fehlen halt
die witcher bäume die sich immer komplett gebogen haben
was für einen sinn hat das eigentlich in dem game mit dem ballon rum zu fliegen
außer dass es gut ausschaut
gut hier hinten erkennt man halt auch dass es nicht echt ist
oh huge ballon physics
schneelandschaften finde ich erkennt man generell jetzt nicht so viel
was für einen sinn hat das iol mit ballon zu fliegen
naja aktuell eigentlich nur zum rum gucken
früher war das anders
da gab es irgendwelche wetterforscher und irgendwelche anderen typen die sachen beobachtet
haben
ähm heute ist wahrscheinlich eher rein zur aussicht
außer du willst irgendwie ähm mit
du willst fast aus dem weltraum runterspringen
dann musst du es auch mit ballon machen
genau
alter hier lässt er sich von der roten hänge verkloppen in your face bam schreckt
trist hat aber ganz schön zugelegt
gewalt an männern was ist hier los
anzeige ist raus
was auch immer
aber umgebungstechnisch ist das wirklich sehr hübsch muss ich sagen
sehr hübsch
die oberweite erscheint mir jetzt ein wenig unrealistisch
aber da gehts ja auch bei rtx ordentlich
ein bisschen sehr prall
ist halt eher was von einem ballon oder besser eher von so nem sandball oder
jetzt schlägt es erst noch ein paar leute zusammen einfach einfach mal random durch
die straße laufen
ein paar leute zusammenschlagen
so sind sie die grills ja
gut aber optisch sieht das wirklich sehr hübsch aus
das muss man sagen
optisch ist wirklich sehr nice
team jennifer oder team trist
weder
also
wenn ich mich zwischen diesen beiden unbedingt entscheiden müsste dann eindeutig jennifer
aber
ich muss euch ich muss da sagen so dass das beste witcher grill ist die blonde aus dem
addon
ich weiß nicht wie die heißt
oder wer auch nice war war wie hieß die sherry
ne
chelly
wie hieß die aus witcher 1 die dann im in im shani
shani war auch nice
shani ist aber wobei shani sieht gar nicht mehr so toll aus
ich das in erinnerung hatte
aber die blonde die die blonde aus dem
das war beste
das gibt's
wie ach ich weiß nicht mehr
keine ahnung
es wird schon so lange her aber ich weiß nicht mehr
so wir gucken uns jetzt cs go fails 2019 an
weil ich muss euch sagen
ich spiele zwar schon kein cs ich spiele schon eine ganze weile kein cs mehr aber
ich gucke mir gerne
immer noch immer noch gerne cs an
und ich muss sagen es ist so mein lieblingszugguck e-sport
nachdem ja starcraft voll abgekackt ist
starcraft hab ich auch immer gerne geguckt
aber
cs ist halt das geile dass es gibt laufend turniere in cs
also es vergeht es vergeht keine woche also eigentlich kein tag wo nicht irgendein cs
turnier ist
und zumindest kein wochenende wo ein cs turnier ist
und
die competition ist halt auch krass
du kannst dir mittlerweile bei cs nicht messen
früher konntest du sagen ey fanatic gewinnt
oder oder oder
zumindest
zumindest waren sie immer wenn sie dabei waren waren sie immer ziemlich gut
aber mittlerweile
mittlerweile ist
ist wirklich
vor allem gewinnt da auch teilweise
kommt auch teams richtig weit
von denen du irgendwie kaum was gehört hast
denkst alle wer ist das so
ich hab kein faf team
ich bin meistens
wenn ich nen cs turnier gucke
ich bin irgendwie meistens immer instinktiv für irgendeine mannschaft
ich hab keine ahnung für warum
für irgendein team
ich kann jetzt immer schlecht sagen warum
so entweder weil sie grad übelst auf den sack gekriegt haben
weil ich will das irgendwie
krasses comeback starten oder irgendwie
ich suche mir das meistens pro turnier neu aus
was ist
ist es für dich ok wenn man deines stream
reaction auf youtube
wenn du willst kannst du das machen ja
das kenne ich
das ist wo der
das ist wo der pokal auseinander fällt
das kenne ich
das ist das wo der pokal auseinander fällt
alter der yoshis island meme song
hast du die witcher serie angesehen
nee noch nicht
ich bin noch am kämpfen mit mir
hoffentlich wirds netflix abo holen
oder nicht
wobei
ich müsste mir eigentlich kein abo holen
ich könnte mir ja nen
test abo holen
jetzt muss ich mich wenigstens nicht schlecht fühlen
wenn ich auch nicht treffe
was
by edward forst everybody to go back toward a and they're swarming
roland tries to do what he can to support his teammate
to get in the door quickly surprisingly twist stays alive
and tarik what are you gonna do here this defense is just getting overrun
was denn da jetzt der große fail na ja man kann auch man kann auch man kann
auch kritischer sein als nötig
er hat sich so schön so schön ein abgelockt dahinter er
ich hoffe ich habe mich gemute ich habe euch nicht gerade übelst ins ohr genossen genießt
aber das war das war schon unglücklich er
also wenn ich trotzdem gehört habt dann ist dann war das so laut dass es trotz
mute knopf noch durchgegangen ist das hat das hat er so schön gelockt hier sich
da in der ecke das ist halt pech das ist halt pech man kann halt passieren weil
den spielern musste halt von ausgehen dass wenn die checken dass du hinter
ihnen bist dass sie dich halt dass sie sich halt einfach rumdrehen bär und den kopf schießen
das ist halt auch schwierig da irgendwie
one on four one on five irgendwie wegzuspray
aber einen sollte man schon mal erwischen ja
zwei
oh man ja gut kann halt immer mal passieren
okay er trifft nix
ich dachte sind turniere nicht irgendwelche streaming geschichten keine ahnung wer das
ist kennt man den der stirbt jetzt direkt
die
ex kaster ok kann vorkommen ja was war das überhaupt für eine map
vertigo genau das sieht man so selten
der
Ja, soll nicht sein.
Ich finde, was ich ja immer beruhigend finde ist,
dass auch den richtigen, guten, Weltklasse-Pros so eine Kacke passiert.
Da bin ich immer beruhigt, weil ich mir manchmal so wie der letzte Aim-Noob vorkomme in Games und nichts treffe.
Und dann bin ich ja froh, dass das teilweise bei Pros auch so ist.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, anteilmäßig passiert das bei mir halt deutlich öfters als bei denen.
Wie oft will man das jetzt noch ausprobieren?
Oh, das war knapp.
Alter.
Das kann ins Auge gehen, ey.
Das kann echt ins Auge gehen.
Ich meine, da geht es jetzt zwar keine 20 Meter runter oder so,
aber wahrscheinlich geht es irgendwie eineinhalb Meter vor der Bühne runter.
Aber wenn du da rückwärts runterfliegst, das kann echt ins Auge gehen.
Aber hier, guckt euch mal die Pro-Gamer-Reactions an hier.
Guckt euch das mal an, wie schnell er ihn festhält.
Guck mal hier, das ist hier mal Pro-Reflexes-Awareness.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich, das habe ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Was?
Oh.
Kann halt mal vorkommen, ja. Kann halt mal passieren.
Oh, shit.
Warum ist der Dude nicht gestorben gerade mit dem Messer?
Warum ist der Messer?
Warum ist der gerade nicht?
Oh, das fuck.
Ah, yes.
What?
Haben wir, haben wir ein Cacomodate-E-Mode? Nein, haben wir nicht.
Wir haben bloß ein Cacona-E-Mode, das passt jetzt aber nicht.
Wir brauchen noch ein, für sowas brauchen wir noch ein neues E-Mode, wir brauchen noch einen.
Den brauchen wir noch.
Moment, Bild, ich brauche Bild.
Und zwar transparent.
Jawoll, gibt es auch eine höhere Auflösung?
Ich gucke mir die anderen Bilder immer gar nicht erst an, falls da, falls da Monkratos drinne ist.
So, jetzt haben wir auch das passende dazu.
Äh, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Jetzt haben wir das passende E-Mode vor.
Ah, yes, alles klar.
Wird rumgestellt.
What? What? What?
Wie zum Teufel konnte das, hat er sich bewegt oder was, wie konnte das vorbeigehen?
Ich mein, mehr auf den Kopf ziehen kannst du nicht.
Der ist voll um den Kopf, Alter.
War nur die Mütze, ja wo soll denn der, also wenn da nicht der Kopf ist, muss dann...
What?
Oh.
Was ich cool finde, was bei CS wirklich nice ist, dass die Observer, die kriegen ja meiner Meinung nach eh ein bisschen zu wenig Credit,
dass die Observer das in der Regel immer ziemlich gut schaffen, ich meine CS ist ja auch kein neues Game, aber dass sie das immer ziemlich gut schaffen zu predikten, wo was wie passiert.
Das ist echt beeindruckend, weil ansonsten ist es ja nicht so, dass da irgendein Caster da sitzt und irgendwie im Overview dann irgendwie castet, während wir was anderes sehen.
Die sehen ja das gleiche und das heißt, irgendjemand muss quasi so regiemäßig machen.
Und dass die Observer das so gut hinkriegen, finde ich echt beeindruckend.
In Korea ist CS nicht so angesagt. Du könntest von ausgehen, wenn CS in Korea so angesagt wäre, wie sagen wir jetzt irgendwie PUBG oder Overwatch oder LoL, dann wären die Koreaner auch so gut.
Gibt es den Typ auch noch?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das war doch eben kein Fail, der hat halt nicht getroffen im Smoke.
Das ist natürlich Pech.
Das hätte echt gut funktionieren können.
Das war aber mega knapp.
Tja, passiert den besten.
Alter, das war Turn-On of Doom. Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich hätte jetzt direkt uninstalled. Ich hätte direkt range quitted.
Handgelenk ist durch, aber ehrlich.
Finger ist abgebrochen.
Das hätte 1 zu 1 ich sein können hier.
Das hätte 1 zu 1 von mir sein können.
Ist die Bombe da reingefallen, die kriegen sie nicht mehr raus oder was?
Das ist natürlich bitter.
Das ist natürlich scheiße.
Ist das ein Feature? Alles Feature. Wenn es kaputt ist, verkauf es als Feature.
Jetzt entschärft er nicht.
Nee, die Bombe explodiert jetzt.
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt, das gab es doch auch letztens so einen Clip, wo sie sich so mega gefreut haben, die Runde ist durch, gewonnen, gewonnen.
Oh, Comrades wieder.
Ja klar.
Das ist zu knapp.
Er ist noch mal in die Richtung geschossen, wo keiner mehr war.
Ist die Zeit abgelaufen, haben die zu spät gelegt?
Ist das knapp.
Ja gut, das kann passieren.
Will er die jetzt mit der Granate zurückholen?
Das wäre jetzt geil gewesen, hätte das doch geklappt.
Da.
Warum genau müssen die da jetzt Yoshis Island Musik im Hintergrund eigentlich laufen lassen?
Wollte lieber eine Runde Quake spielen oder irgendwie, oder Modern Warfare Jumpshot mit seinem Scuff-Controller.
Pass mal auf.
WTF, warum jumpt er jetzt hier raus, wie verrückt.
Doch, der wollte in die Luftschacht gucken, ob da was drin ist, gehe ich mal von aus.
Ich habe richtig gecheckt, dass da einer steht, aber es sah halt schon ein bisschen aus, als wäre das ein Scuff-Jumpshot.
Oh nee, bitte her.
Das hätte ich noch durchdrücken müssen, aber passiert halt.
Was geht denn am Hintergrund ab?
Was geht mit dem Gaster ab?
Hauptsache der Gaster kann sich freuen.
Tja.
Das kenne ich, das habe ich gesehen.
Das genau, das muss die Bombe suchen.
Das kenne ich, das habe ich schon gesehen.
Das hat die Runde gemacht schon vorher.
Also diese 10 Spiele muss man 2019 gespielt haben, ja dann Game Start, dann zeige uns mal her, dann zeigen wir, was müssen wir gespielt haben, was davon haben wir nicht gespielt, wahrscheinlich alles.
Fortnite, nein Fortnite muss man nicht unbedingt gespielt haben.
Welche CPUs würde dir empfehlen, wenn man sich einen neuen Gaming-PC zusammenbaut? AMD-CPUs.
Irgendein Ryzen deiner Wahl in der passenden Preiskategorie, was je nachdem was du ausgehen willst.
Sind das Spiele oder sind das PC-Spiele?
Weil 10 Spiele insgesamt ist kein Ding.
PC-Spiele.
Oh Game Star Humor.
Auf das Gamertop kann Bock.
Das ist der Quake 2 Mod.
Der RTX Mod.
Aber Leute, bei Quake klickt es auch daran, dass Quake 2 für heute einfach ziemlich kantig aussieht.
Und es sehr schön viele Flächen hat, wo man schön RTX Spiegelung machen kann.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde, es sieht definitiv gut aus.
Aber ich finde, es sieht irgendwie fehlplatziert aus in Quake 2.
Ich meine, guckt euch das Wasser an und guckt euch im Vergleich die irgendwie in diesen Bodentext an.
Das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Was für ein Seitenverhältnis ist das hier eigentlich, in was er da spielt?
20.000 zu 5 oder wie?
Ich meine, WTF? 21 zu 9 müsste das sein.
Aber trotzdem hätte man das Video nicht in irgendeiner etwas gängigeren Variante aufnehmen können.
Ich weiß, das ist 21 zu 9, aber hätte es doch durchaus in einer etwas gängigeren Variante aufnehmen können, oder?
Dafür muss dann aber auch der Inhalt stimmen und deshalb nochmal eine Zeitreise zurück in die 90er.
Denn mit Resident Evil 2 liefert Capcom 2019 das perfekte Remake eines über 20 Jahre alten Spiels ab.
Das wollte ich mir auch nochmal geben.
Das Remake transportiert alle alten Stärken des Survival Horror Sequels in die Gegenwart, modernisiert an genau den richtigen Stellen den Spielablauf und präsentiert das Ganze in der bildhübschen und gleichzeitig eklig fiesen RE Engine.
So gibt es eigentlich für niemanden mehr eine Ausrede, den Horror Klassiker verpasst zu haben.
Capcom liefert mit diesem Must-Play außerdem ganz nebenbei die Blaupause, wie das perfekte Remake eines Klassikers auszusehen hat.
Was? Ernsthaft?
Das muss man nicht gespielt haben.
Vor allem, könnt ihr euch noch an die Story für Ring Fit erinnern?
Wo man die Welt vor einem Bodybuilder Dämonen retten muss?
Jetzt ist es ernsthaft. Du musst die Welt vor einem Bodybuilder Dämonen retten.
Ihr wisst ja, was ich bei den Nintendo Werbung immer toll finde, dass da immer die ganze Familie im Wohnzimmer sitzt und Spiele spielt, was so halt in der Realität nie vorkommt.
NIE! Das ist genauso realitätsfremd wie damals die Kinect Werbung, wo auch Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder, wo dann großer Bruder mit kleiner Schwester Xbox-Tanzspiele gespielt hat.
Das ist total realitätsfremd.
Sehr gut genervt.
Wahrscheinlich kann man das wieder genauso gut bescheißen wie damals mit der Wii-Mode, wo du anstatt die Wii-Mode zu schwingen einfach nur das Handgelenk wackeln musstest und sowas.
Der Chat wieder.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Komischer Grafikstil.
Nicht meins. Soll richtig gut sein, habe ich gehört, aber nicht meins.
Eindeutig Residenzliefer.
Nicht meins.
Ist das die, ey, das Facemodel von der hier?
Wartet mal.
Das Facemodel von der, das ist doch original die aus Wolfenstein, oder?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die hieß.
Wie hieß die denn in Wolfenstein?
Characters.
Die da, die da. Hier.
Das ist die doch. Die sehen sich total ähnlich.
Andere, andere Aufmachung, aber das Facemodel ist garantiert die gleiche.
Moment, wo habe ich denn jetzt das andere?
Das ist die. Das ist die, guckt euch das mal an. Das ist gar nicht das gleiche Facemodel.
Auch von den Gesichtszügen und sowas sieht sehr ähnlich aus.
Alter, der Chat wieder.
Oh, da freue ich mich drauf.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Sieht ja sehr spannend aus.
Hm, Bogensimulator.
Okay, das ist gut für ein VR Spiel.
Baba.
Ja, mag ganz nett sein, aber ist nichts, was ich jetzt unbedingt spielen müsste.
Game Star Humor.
Also ganz mal ernsthaft, wenn das die Topspiele 2010 sind, da gab es aber 2010 nicht allzu viel, oder?
Ja, 2019.
Ich muss jetzt nicht wissen, dass mir irgendwie einer in World of Warcraft mal wieder den Furz gelassen hat oder so. Aber gut, das bringt halt Klicks, die müssen auch gucken, wo sie bleiben.
neue fähigkeiten wie doppelsprung oder welchen zeitschrift ist besser als die
game star oder welches welches klassische gaming
journalist mussten was war medium ist besser als die game star um die cleveren
umgebungsrätsel zu lösen neue abkürzungen zu eröffnen
alles toll aber immer noch das beste was es gibt
centimeter für centimeter untertarn zu machen
etf was soll das alles sein also das sind jetzt alle spiele wo ich nicht wirklich bock drauf hab
auf steam steht supra land mit über 3000 reviews auf äußerst positiv das alles wäre für ein mittelgroßes
indie team schon sensationell supra land wurde aber weitestgehend von einem einzigen
entwickler im allein gang gemacht david münich aus deutschland und das muss man gespielt haben
ums zu glauben das beste rollenspiel des jahres ist weder ich hab's mir überlegt ob ich mir das
kaufen soll ja aber das sah in den forst in den also gar nicht die ganzen
vorschau videos und was gesehen hab sah das so unglaublich langwierig aus dass ich es mir nicht gekauft hab
fantasy noch sci-fi pfeift auf third person kamera oder eine riesige 3d open world und kämpfe gibt's
auch keine trotzdem erobert der kleine indie entwickler sah um mit disco illusium 2019 kritiker
und spieler herzen das liegt zunächst mal an der unglaublichen spiel tiefe denn obwohl man auf die
rolle eines polizisten festgelegt ist kann man sehr frei entscheiden was für ein polizist man ist
je nach vorliebe spielt man entweder einen aggressiven alkoholiker einen brillanten ermittler
oder irgendwas dazwischen unser eigenbaukorb soll dann in der fiktiven stadt mit ihren
heruntergekommen also ich wäre für den ehemaligen pro gamer den ich das spiele und das eigentlich
schon seit drei tagen mehr weiß er nämlich nicht mehr also zu spielbeginn mit dem größten
kater und film ist nackig in unterhosen btf untergekommenen wohnung aufwacht oder ist das
überhaupt seine wohnung disco illusium lässt nahezu alle ermittlungs ansätze zu und eröffnet
selbst wenn man mal scheitern sollte neue möglichkeiten statt eines game over bildschirms
überhaupt gibt es keinen wirklich roten faden an denen der spieler gebunden ist wann man wo
ermittelt steht also jedem frei auch in sachen gruppen management geht disco illusium neue wege
denn statt verschiedenem partymitgliedern führt unser korb steht selbstgespräche mit teilen
seiner psyche und zankt sich somit seiner empathie logik das war also wäre eigentlich ein game für
mich aber das hat mir gar so langwierigen eindruck gemacht sehr viel text die es bisher auch nur auf
englisch gibt wer sich dessen mächtig fühlt wird dafür aber mit interessanten charakteren
lebendigen dialogen und einer der tollsten rollenspielerfahrung der spielegeschichte
belohnt los spielen jetzt seit jahren hat mich kein spiel mehr so positiv überrascht
ja das wollte ich mir auch noch geben das wollte ich mir auch noch geben soll man nämlich ein
handgebautes kleines sonnensystem erkunden das in einer zeitschleife gefangen ist und dabei
stolpert man zu fuß oder im kleinen raumschiff alle nase lang über faszinierende naturphänomene
interessante hintergrund story häppchen und sau coole gameplay ideen die open sind das nicht schon
mehr als zehn gäbe ich auch nicht wie man dort hinkommt werden aber vermutlich keine zwei spieler weltweit auf die
gleiche weise bewerkstelligen das blöde daran je mehr ich euch über autowilds erzähle dass
so weniger knallen die überraschungen wenn er sie selbst herausfindet und das ist schließlich der
große reiz am spiel also vertraut mir einfach wenn ich euch sage dass man dieses kleine meisterwerk
einfach gespielt haben muss und danach alle bekannten dazu zwingen muss es auch zu spielen
bei kaum einem spiel ging in dieses jahr die meinungen mehr als bei der stranding der dhl
simulator je nachdem wem man zuhört ist das entweder ein künstlerisch anspruchsvolles meisterwerk
oder ein totlangweiliger postboten simulator recht haben irgendwie beide lager denn das ist die
crux an der stranding man kann die faszination daran wirklich nur sehr schwer in wort und bild
erklären man muss es eigentlich selbst gespielt haben auf dem weg die mysteriöse story von das
drenning zu enträtseln liefert man als sogenannter porter das ist der auswalk in der welt voller
geisterwesen und räuberbanden pakete aus das beste an der stranding war doch eigentlich die
letzten jahre die verwirrung drum was es eigentlich ist oder das war doch das beste an dem game wo
bei jedem trailer und bei jedem häppchen alle wieder rum gerätselt haben so was ist das jetzt
was passiert da eigentlich was ist das das für einen typ das fand ich im vorfeld gut das game
jetzt so geil geworden ist weiß nicht mal geht es nur geradeaus durch den tal mal auf den schnee
bedeckten gipfel eines von geisterwesen heimgesuchten bergs der spaß liegt also darin durch kluge
planung mit der 3d karte nebst wettervorhersage für jeden weg und jede witterung das passende
equipment wie seile leiter in ersatzschuhe oder waffen mitzubringen und so möglichst effiziente
lieferrouten zu planen das ist bei zeiten schon ziemlich einsam und offline ist man dabei wirklich
komplett auf sich gestellt online können spieler aber die spuren und das finde ich eine coole
idee ihre vorgänger finden und sich so gegenseitig helfen das macht die reise nicht nur deutlich
angenehmer sondern hat zumindest in mir den glauben an das gute im menschen wiederhergestellt
und welches andere spiel schafft das schon du kannst ja wohl irgendwie auch so eine prücke
oder kannst ja wohl irgendwie eine prücke hinsetzen dann müssen leute materialen für sammeln
überhaupt ein titel am besten noch irgendwas kleines was dieses jahr völlig zu unrecht
untergegangen ist und man unbedingt gespielt haben muss dann ab damit in die kommentare
das waren also die must plays 2019 schon im letzten jahr die spiele gezeigt warum genau
ist er jetzt im bild ist da humor hilfe hilfe nein es tut weh ich kann sie nicht angucken
aber eins muss man sagen die bringen den gleichen cringe seit zehn jahren oder länger ja
okay wir gucken jetzt evolution of game of the year winner also wir gucken uns jetzt
die game of the year an von 1979 bis 2019 1979 was soll da gewesen sein da gab es mich
noch nicht und den chat gab es damals garantiert auch noch nicht wen von euch gab es überhaupt
jemand von euch da schon also mich gab es noch nicht deswegen gehe ich mal von aus
den chat wird es da wahrscheinlich auch nicht gegeben haben keinen im chat okay gucken wir
mal spät der sound
was hat das kenne ich noch das kenne ich auf jeden ollen computer sehr gut das ist
eine sache die kennt der ein oder andere noch dass er mario wenigstens aus wie mario ich
habe keine ahnung was das sein soll huge graphics gut das kennt jeder warum trifft
er das ding nicht das kennen auch jeder ich habe keine ahnung was das sein soll die zuschauer
sehen ja nahezu fotorealistischer aus und wenn das ist ein spiel des jahres fucking
pinball wie pinball ist bieter glauben aber gut das kennen wir auch alle weil das nicht
das gameboy tetris ist beste beste du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du du
du du du du du du du du ja das kann auch alle
ja jetzt klar busi alles klar was mich ja ans wisst ihr was mich ja an sonic am meisten
verstört das ist gar nicht sonic selbst sondern die ganzen fan kreationen die es zu sonic
gibt das ist teilweise echt verstörende und die sounds gewalt gegen frauen tos
oh da beste auch sehr nice auch gut das erste donki das war cool das zweite auch das erste
fand ich richtig nice damals der spielt das doch auf in einem emulator in 300 mal 200
oder so ganz so pixellig sah es auf n64 doch auch nicht aus oder das hat zwar pixellig
aus aber so pixellig sah das doch nie aus mario hatte nie solche pixel der sah der sah
kantig aus aber nicht pixellig das ist auf jeden fall komische grafik kann das sein
dass das das dass das dass das kein video vom n64 ist sondern video vom 3d form vom
ds das overrated the game aller zeiten leute das ist so overrated kann das gar nicht beschreiben
will ich sagen das feine fertig schlecht ist aber es ist nicht dass das ultimative beste
game aller zeiten wie das feine fertig sieben fans dahinstellen immer zumal man auch sagen
muss also viel verwirrende und und merkwürdiger kann ja eine story kaum werden
huge beste ein bisschen länger hätte man jetzt auch kamine oft heim auch zeigen können
oja da kann man dran erinnern das erste sims das einzige sims was ich gespielt habe das erste
weil es hat mal was neues irgendwo innovatives war ja übrigens wir müssen aber zurück zum
letzten fein dass sie sich mal aufgefallen wie viel besser die umgebung und die grafik wurde
im vergleich zu feiner fantasy sieben obwohl es auf der gleichen konsole war weil da liegen
welten dazwischen zwischen dem und das was mein feiner fantasy sieben gesehen hat
gta 3 das war auch ein ich glaube wenn ich sogar das einzige gta was ich gespielt habe
ich nicht gespielt sport spiele
die san Andreas habe ich gespielt
oh das war gut ja ich würde sogar sagen mein lieblingsversie denn ebel
oh das war auch gut also wenn ich eine liste machen müsste so eines der sag mal mal nicht
nicht besten gms aller zeiten sondern so eines der erinnerungswürdig so die die am
meisten im kopf geblieben sind da ist bioshock auf jeden fall mit dabei
was sagt er eigentlich auf deutsch würdest du bitte oder was was sagt er auf deutsch
eigentlich hat das jemand von euch gespielt auf deutsch
chat wir können einfach mal google google fragen
wer ist du so freundlich sagt er wer ist du so freundlich ich zeige es euch jetzt nicht
weil vielleicht die ein oder andere leute bioshock nicht gespielt haben sollte jetzt
noch nicht gespielt haben müsste das auch unbedingt spielen also es ist auf jeden fall
eines der games die mir am meisten in erinnerung geblieben sind
wo ist das erste anschaute erste anschaute war das beste
noch mehr gta also wild west gta wie viele wie viele fuchs rodar collections und und
compilation ist damals gab hat mich null gejuckt hat mich null gejuckt telltale gibt
er mittlerweile immer noch mehr gta spannenderes gameplay ist jetzt nicht eingefallen das ist
von 2013 ja das ist gta 5 ist uralt wie das war ein spiel des jahres ernsthaft train age
inquisition das hat gesagt ja witcher 3 das verstehe ich
witcher 3 hat er kein bock richtiges gameplay zu bringen das ist das ist ja richtig uralt
footage da sah gerard noch ganz anders aus das ist eines der ersten trailer von der spielwelt
guckt euch mal an guck mal da sah gerard noch ganz anders aus
als der hätte man der hätte man nichts besser haben sie nichts besseres gefunden oder was
ohje ohje da habe ich also meine persönliche beziehung zu dem gamer außer dem time to
sleep hat er nie gesagt ja das voll das kann ich nachvollziehen spooky algeholic stufe 1
dankeschön habe ich immer noch nicht gespielt habe ich immer noch nicht gespielt mein problem
ist eigentlich will ich es auch gar nicht mal spielen weil ich habe mir komplett komplett
das let's play angeguckt und ich weiß halt was passiert wobei ich den wobei ich die story
ende ziemlich gut fand schreckt in your face next bg dankeschön spooky algeholic
das war doch niemals game des jahres ich meine wenigstens ein schlechtes aber na gut
dieses jahr gab es nicht wirklich viel war das game des jahres echt ok ja gut es gab
ja was gab es dieses jahr sonst noch großartiges das ist übrigens ganz anfang vom game oder
ziemlich am anfang also wenn es ein fail game des jahres gibt dann ist es definitiv
anthem 2 war 2018 stimmt stimmt stimmt das kam ja jetzt erst auf dem pc ich hab das
gerade durch jahre richtig evolution of was ist mit dem leuten los top speed running moments
worst games da bin ich ja fast geneigt dass wir uns zusammengucken worst games da fallen
wir ein paar ein boppel twitch prime drei monate dankeschön
orsonic forces hör mal auf gefahrt gefahrt anthem ist müll
von meinen Twitter-Followern, aber ich habe entdeckt, dass sogar das kontroversial sein kann.
Die Leute waren wütend, dass Kingdom Hearts 3 und Skyward Sword überhaupt auf der Liste waren,
obwohl sie einen schweren Kritik hatten. Und weißt du was? Ich habe es ein bisschen begleitet.
Du kannst nicht wirklich Spiele wie diese neben unvergessliche Messe,
wie Ride to Hell Retribution, in völlig anderen Ballparken, spielen.
Also habe ich entschieden, dass wir einen neuen Angle benötigen.
Instead of the objectively worst experiences of the 2010s, today let's take a look at the 10 most disappointing titles of the last 10 years.
There are probably hundreds, maybe thousands of absolutely atrocious games that could be considered the worst, but no one has played, and that wouldn't make for as interesting of a list anyway.
This way, I'm more or less looking at these entries from the view of public perception and why they failed to deliver on the hype people had for them.
I guess what I'm trying to say is, don't kill me, please. Blame the hashtag, AngryGamersQuad. Alright, let's get started.
No Man's Sky, promised a game we'd never seen before.
Das musste ja drin sein.
Aber eine Sache, bevor jetzt das Game total trashed, eine Sache muss man dem Spiel mal wirklich zugute halten.
Nach dem absolut verkackten Marketing vor Release und der verkackte Release im Vergleich zu dem, was die Leute erwartet haben, der Support für das Spiel ist nicht schlecht.
Also, die haben sich das wirklich zu Herzen genommen, die arbeiten immer noch an dem Game dran, das Game kriegt immer noch größere Patches,
und mittlerweile muss es ein deutlich, ein wirklich, ich hab's ja nicht, weiß ich nicht, aber von allem, was man liest und auch was Leute sagen, muss es ein deutlich, deutlich besseres Game sein, als es bei Release gewesen ist.
Also, bevor er das jetzt komplett schlecht redet.
Wenn was eins, kann man sich merken, wenn was zu gut aussieht, als wahr zu sein, oder wenn was so gut aussieht, also besser als, dass es wahr sein könnte, dann ist es meistens nicht wahr.
Aber, es haben sich doch am ersten Tag, könnt ihr euch noch vielleicht dran erinnern, am ersten Tag oder am zweiten Tag haben sich doch Leute auf dem gleichen Planet getroffen, und es kam raus, der Multiplayer hat gar nicht funktioniert.
Die Spieler wurden einfach nicht angezeigt.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, also da kann man echt nicht meckern, also die haben sich das zu Herzen genommen.
Oh ja, das hab ich ja schon wieder ganz verdrängt, aber Spiele, die nie erscheinen, wurden ja mittlerweile durch Half-Life 3 abgelöst.
Duke Nukem Forever war gar nicht so dermaßen scheiße, aber es war halt extrem weit von dem weg, was man, was man so erwartet hat, und es war halt komplett out of place, oder es hat sich komplett deplatziert angefühlt in dem Jahr, wo es rausgekommen ist.
Es hat sich gespielt wie ein Game von 99, wahrscheinlich fand ich es deswegen ganz okay.
Du hättest gedacht, dass Lüge am besten juvenile waren und am schlimmsten offensiv waren. Du hättest deinen eigenen Kuss für irgendeinen verdammten Grund holen können, aber aufgrund all das hatte es klunkige Kontrollen, eine Abundanz von Glitches, und verabschiedete Mechaniken aus den vorherigen Duke Nukem Erinnerungen.
Die Spieler waren flabbergastet, wie das passieren könnte, wenn man so lange warten würde.
Dieses Spiel hält den Weltrekord für den längtesten Entwicklungsprozess, und das Ergebnis ist lebendige Wahrheit, dass Zeit im Ofen nicht gleiche Qualität ist.
Nach der tiefen und kapitulierenden Welt der Dragon Age Serie waren die Fans bereit für das neue IP BioWare, das nächstes Projekt gearbeitet hat.
Leider war das nur ein blanderes Spiel, genutzt von schmutzigen Entwicklungsideen und zu vielen Mikrotransaktionen. Anthem war nur so freundlich, als ob es unendlich war.
Und wenn ein Spiel versucht, eine große Postlaunch-Kommunität zu fördern, hat es lachend schwere Endgame-Kontakte.
The Frostbite Engine, as beautiful as it looks, does not fit every type of game. In any way, it seemed to bite off more than they could chew with this title. It ended up as little more than a snoozefest.
It's hard to forget that it launched with game-crashing bugs, some that even bricked entire consoles.
Und die haben ja keiner geglaubt. Die haben gesagt, das wird schon huge, wie das aussieht, so ein geiles Game. Aber nein, es wurde scheiße.
That's why Animal Crossing Amiibo Festival was such a colossal letdown.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
And removed all the mini-games, as well as any strategy for winning, you'd have Amiibo Festival.
Players walk around a board and watch cutscenes while they gain happy points, until someone is declared the victor.
That is basically the whole game.
This is easily the most boring experience on this list, and really is the entry that least resembles an actual video game at all.
As the second mediocre Animal Crossing spin-off game to release in the same year, it's clear that this was just a quick cash grab, created as an attempt to sell more Amiibo.
You're required to have one if you want to play the game at all. So good luck if you bought it secondhand, but it looks like gamers weren't fooled by this facade.
It only sold 20 to 30 thousand copies in Japan.
That is incredible.
The second Bioware need to make this, OUCH, Mass Effect Andromeda was a kind of antistatic game.
People were ready to jump back into that world and explore the galaxy, but instead were met with this, and this.
The majority of Andromeda's issues all stem from lack of polish.
It appeared to be rushed out the door before getting to the end of the game, but it was not the end of the game.
People were met with this, and this. The majority of Andromeda's issues all stem from lack of polish. It appeared to be rushed out the door before getting to the end of the game, but it was not the end of the game.
Yet again, EA forcing restrictions on development led to horror stories from the main game directors quitting, and the horror animation crew was drastically understaffed, leading to goofy memes and a myriad of glitches to be spreading across the world.
But the lack of adding anything new or interesting to the franchise was the final nail in the coffin.
Some stand by its quality in some areas, and while its vast poor reception may not be entirely warranted,
it gives one reminder of what happens when a secondary team meets massive deadline crunch and runs into numerous problems and staff changes along the way.
You could make the argument that Sonic Boom! Rise of Lyric was expected to blow anyone's socks off, but in retrospect I think it's easy to say that it's the Sonic 06 of this decade, or possibly even worse.
At least that was fun in a so bad it's good way. This is just so unbelievably generic and slow that it hardly feels like it belongs in the series at all.
Boring puzzles, lethargic combat and extremely annoying characters that never shut up are everywhere in this title, you'll feel like banging your head against the wall.
But that's to say nothing about the insanely terrible framerate and overall jankiness, it feels like a cart that's barely hanging on by a single bolt and could fall apart at any moment.
It's pretty impressive that a game could ship with such low quality and be so unremarkable at the same time.
To put it in the immortal words of Barry Kramer, it's just, it's just, I don't know, this game cost $60.
But hey, at least we got a half decent cartoon out of it, that's something.
Ah, the game that ruined one of my favorite franchises. Sticker Star was the first and only handheld Paper Mario game, but that's not why it's so heavily panned.
This began the tradition of creating creative and original characters...
Ich mein, ich hab ja nen 3DS, ne? Der 3DS, das ist wieder so ein typischer Failkauf gewesen bei mir.
Der 3DS, den hab ich gekauft, mit zwei Spielen.
Ein Spiel hab ich mittlerweile, äh, wie nennt man das, ich sag mal gespendet, als Preis für nen Event.
Ähm, das andere hab ich unserem Nachbar geschenkt, den, und mein 3DS, der ist noch hier und liegt halt rum.
Das einzige, was ich mit dem gemacht habe, ist die WLAN-Einrichtung. Komplett Fail eigentlich, ne?
... für die einfachsten Mario-Einrichtungen und keine Charme oder Unikität. Aber noch schlimmer, sie haben die mechanische Deptheit von den originalen Spielen verwendet, und anstatt das mit einem einfachen Sticker-System verwendet, wobei jeder Attack eine einmalige Nutzung hat.
Gemeinsam mit dem Fakt, dass die Erfahrungspunkte komplett entfernt wurden, hat das logisch zu tun, dass man keinen Grund hat, sich überhaupt zu kämpfen.
Es hat mehr Sinn gemacht, alles zu verhindern und die besten Attacken für die entsprechenden Kämpfe zu verpacken.
Super Paper Mario war kontroversial, aber sieht aus, als wäre es ein Masterpiece im Vergleich.
Diese und viele andere Kopfschritte haben uns mit einem empty Custard von Super Paper Mario geblieben, und es hat noch nicht gekämpft, seitdem.
Star Wars Battlefront...
Also ein Paper Mario fand ich gut. Ich weiß nicht mehr, welches das gewesen ist. Ich glaub, das war das erste.
Das erste war auf dem Gamecube, oder?
Irgendwas mit Dora. Hier. Das da, ja, das war gut. Das hat mir gefallen.
Das erste Paper Mario.
Auf dem Gamecube? Nee, doch Gamecube.
Das da. Das war nice. Das war cool.
Es reicht schon, wenn ich diesen Titel sehe.
Auch wieder so ein Game, das die Welt nicht gebraucht hat.
Ja. So verkackt wieder.
Surprise Mechanics.
Ist ja auch da, wo Disney sich eingeschaltet hat damals.
Oh, das ist gut.
Oh, das war der Megaman-Abklatsch.
Aber eins muss man ihnen zugute halten. Ohne Scheiß, eins muss man ihnen zugute halten.
Und nicht einfach sang und klanglos, wie manche andere Projekte vor die Wand. Sie haben es vor die Wand gefahren, aber sie haben es nicht einfach sang und klanglos unter den Teppich gekehrt. Sie haben es wenigstens rausgebracht. Es war kacke danach, als es rausgekommen ist. Aber immerhin.
Das stimmt voll.
Oh nein, Fallout.
Da haben wir uns ja das komplette Video zu angeguckt.
Am besten bei der ganzen Geschichte war ja einmal die Cola und dass die Leute in irgendeinem Developer-Room konnten und sich Items duken. Das war das Highlight. Aber die Cola hat es nochmal getoppt.
Oder der Rucksack. Aber die Cola war schon echt top. Die Tasche, genau nicht der Rucksack, die Tasche war es.
Haha, ist das erschissen aber.
Die Tasche war auch geil. Das mit der Tasche war auch geil. Den Leuten haben sie quasi eine Collector's Edition-Tasche, eine Fallout-Tasche versprochen. Und es kam nicht und es kam nicht und es wurde nicht fertig. Es wurden immer Sachen versprochen.
Und am Ende kam dann raus, dass irgendwelche YouTube-Influencer und wichtige Leute die ordentliche Tasche bekommen haben. Aber die Leute, die Collector's Edition pre-ordert haben halt nicht. Und um das Ganze dann noch zu toppen, hat man eine Ultra-Crap-Tasche bekommen. Das billigste AliExpress vom billigsten.
Und man hat 500 Ingame-Währungen bekommen. Und mit der Ingame-Währung, die man bekommen hat als Entschädigung, konnte man sich noch nicht mal die Tasche, die man nicht bekommen hat, in-game kaufen.
Und dafür sind die Leute natürlich ausgeflippt.
Ich muss sagen, es war eine gute Liste. Es war eine gute Liste. Alles war wirklich komplett Fail.
Aber das war eine gute Liste.
Das letzte Star Fox war auch Crap.
Also ich glaube von einer Sache können wir uns verabschieden, dass das die nächsten 10 Jahre wirklich besser wird.
Das wird, also so wie das jetzt aktuell aussieht, wird es die nächsten 10 Jahre eher noch schlimmer.
Allerdings, einen Lichtblick gibt es ja, dass es immer mehr kleine Projekte gibt. Leider geht das halt in dem riesen Haufen Shit, den es auf Steam so gibt, meist ein bisschen unter.
Aber dass es immer mal kleine Projekte gibt, die einen begeistern können. Aber bei AAA-Spielen wird das glaube ich nicht besser.
Und man sieht das ja auch. Blizzard war so der letzte Verein, der so lange Zeit auch von den Fans hochgehalten wurde.
So nach dem Motto, ja was Blizzard macht ist gut.
Aber sogar da ist es jetzt offensichtlich, dass dort die falschen Leute an den wichtigen Positionen sitzen, was zumindest die Spielqualität angeht.
Was Money Money angeht, sitzen da wahrscheinlich die richtigen Leute.
Ich meine Overwatch 2, wenn wirklich Overwatch 2 in dieser Art und Weise rauskommt, wie es jetzt ist, dann ist es halt ein Witz, es Overwatch 2 zu nennen.
Anstatt, es ist halt wie ich gesagt habe, weil sie den Ankündigungstoyler gezeigt haben, im Prinzip ist es Overwatch Season 2, es ist Overwatch 1 ganz normal mit ein bisschen zusätzlichem Content.
CD Projekt wäre doch ein positives Beispiel, ja.
Es ist nicht so, dass es immer Ausnahmen gibt, es gibt immer welche wo es ganz gut ist, wobei man das ja auch nicht vergleichen kann.
Die machen ein Game und da arbeiten sie dann 5 Jahre dran und dann kommt wieder mal ein Game und sowas raus.
Blizzard hat ja viele Sachen parallel und da läuft ja auch nichts mehr wirklich.
Ja was Cyberpunk angeht, müssen wir gucken.
Valve auch ja, wobei, was hat Valve für Games gemacht in den letzten Jahren?
Architekt, was verkackt wurde, ihr komischer Autochess abklatscht, ihr Dota Autochess abklatscht, der irgendwie auch nicht mehr richtig supportet wird, den sie irgendwie schon gleich eingestellt haben nach Release, so halb.
Das Einzige, was die halt am Start haben, jetzt ist CS und Dota 2, aber das ist ja auch nichts Neues und man muss halt dazu sagen, die haben es halt auch nicht nötig.
Die haben halt Steam, genau, die haben halt Steam, die müssen gar nicht.
Die denken sich auch, lenkt mich, wozu soll ich Games machen, wenn ich mit Steam einfach das 20 Billionfache verdiene von Games?
Die Steam Winter Sale Recommendations, die können wir uns jetzt auch noch angucken.
Gucken wir mal, was wir uns unbedingt kaufen müssen beim Steam Winter Sale.
Oh, Quickmuffs.
Euros, endlich.
Okay, doch nicht Cocona, eher England.
Der war gut, ja.
Ich muss euch sagen, das letzte Doom, ich bin übrigens mal gespannt auf das nächste, das letzte Doom, an sich fand ich ein richtig cooles Game, ich hab ja sogar eines der wenigen Review Videos, die ich gemacht hab.
Ich fand das an sich richtig gut, was mir als fast einziges auf den Keks gegangen ist, beim letzten Doom, war tatsächlich die ganzen Animationsgeschichten.
Und dass sie halt auch must have waren, also du musstest quasi die Gegner finishen, anstatt sie einfach nur abzuknallen.
Weil wenn du die Gegner gefinished hast mit dieser finisher Animation, hast du halt einfach mehr Drops bekommen.
Aber das war gut, also wer das nicht gespielt hat, sollte das spielen.
Ja, wer das nicht hat, sollte sich das echt kaufen.
Ah, da hab ich ein paar Video Let's Plays zugesehen, das ist wirklich cool, aber das ist halt nix, was man alleine spielt.
Aber die Idee finde ich cool.
Also als Spieler bekommst du quasi das Handbuch zu diesem Gerät hier, zu so einer Bombe oder was das halt sein soll, bekommst du das Handbuch.
Und der andere hat halt nur die Bombe und der eine muss halt quasi anhand des Handbuches Anleitungen geben, wie der andere die Bombe entschärft.
Das ist jetzt nix, was man dauerhaft spielt irgendwie, aber von der Idee her finde ich es gut.
Das wollte ich mir auch mal geben, habt ihr das gespielt? Chat?
Das wollte ich mir nochmal geben, lohnt sich das?
Ist gut, ok.
Sieht aus wie dumm aus.
Das ist ein Game, das regt mich nur auf.
Musenix, Stufe 1, 5 Monate, Dankeschön.
Nee, hab ich nix übersehen.
Overwatch Q-Time, dafür ist es wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht, aber das Game regt mich nur auf.
Ey, Leute, ich muss euch ein Video zeigen, ich muss euch ein Video zeigen.
Übels krass, jetzt wo wir gerade bei schwierigen Games sind, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern an die Zeit, wo Guita Hero und Rock Band angesagt waren?
Ich hab letztens ein Video gefunden, da spielt einer Trumps 100%.
Übels krass, warte mal, übels krass.
Es kommt gleich, das ist ja doch normal, das krieg ich auch noch hin.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, ey.
Alter, das ist nicht 8-Bit-Trummer, nee.
Der hat geübt, darf man das, warum soll man das nicht dürfen?
Der geht halt ab.
Schlaganfall.
Mal nachher erst mal 100 zu rufen.
Es ist so insane, ey.
Ob man, ob jemand, ob jemand, der das spielen kann, Schlagzeug in Rock Band, ob der das auch halbwegs hinbekommen würde auf einem echten Schlagzeug,
weil ich meine, die Sachen, die du drücken musst, sind ja wahrscheinlich auf 100% identisch.
Ich meine, auf einem echten Schlagzeug musst du halt noch ein bisschen auf mehr achten, als dass du einfach nur triffst, aber halbwegs gut sollte sich doch trotzdem anhören.
Man hört es ja auch von ihm, dass es vom Rhythmus und vom Park passt halt.
Aber er ist hart, oder?
Es ist krass.
Der hat geübt.
Warum lernt man nicht gleich echt spielen? Weil du ihm echt keine Streaks machen kannst.
Vor allem, ne? Der Song geht ja nur 8 Minuten.
Der hat das halt auch komplett auswendig drinnen. Der guckt garantiert nicht mehr auf den Bildschirm.
Ne, der achtet nicht auf die Symbole.
Ja, es ist garantiert leiser als echtes. Aber ich finde es hart.
Vor allem, es geht ja nur 8 Minuten. Danach bist du bestimmt ganz schön geschwitzt.
Vor allem ist es auch noch leise Musik. Was macht eigentlich Kabum? Ich weiß es nicht.
Der hat echt drauf, oder?
Wohingegen ja Gitarre und Bass spielen, bei Guitar Hero wahrscheinlich nicht so viel mit Realität zu tun hat. Schlagzeug halt schon.
Aber der ist echt guter Typ.
Der Chet auch.
Vor allem heutzutage, ne? Heutzutage streamt man auf Twitch live, wie man Schlagzeug spielt und der Chet freut sich.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie lange er geübt hat. Wie lange meint er, dauert das bis man sowas kann?
Also ich meine damit nicht komplett neue Schlagzeug zu lernen, sondern angenommen, der kann Schlagzeug spielen und nur den Song zu lernen.
Zwei Tage, ja ganz bestimmt.
13 Tage.
Ja, Oso drehen die Leute auch komplett ab.
Der ist ein bisschen außer Puste.
So, gleich hat er es geschafft.
Te Uren ist es, genau.
Echt Pock.
Ja, der ist bestimmt ziemlich stinkig, wenn der sich ver- schlägt zwischendurch.
Oh, gleich fertig.
Der freut sich zurecht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du streamt schon eine ganze Weile.
Leute, wir gucken noch in Battlefield Top Plays, muss da nämlich auch weg.
Aber wollen wir mal in Battlefield 5 Top Plays gucken oder wollen wir mal wieder wie gehabt Battlefield 3 und 4 Top Plays gucken?
Winter Cell, ok Winter Cell, Winter Cell müssen wir noch fertig gucken.
Ist das nicht das Game mit Twitch Integration?
Das Game hat doch Twitch Integration, oder?
Das war doch das mit Twitch Integration, wo dann immer auch Chat-Spieler gespawrt sind.
Das spritzt das Pixelblut.
Haben die da nicht kompletten DLC-Sellout gemacht in Payday 2?
Ist das nicht das mit dem, die haben doch eben noch den Cellout gestartet.
Ja, das kann man sich gönnen, wenn man es noch nicht hat.
Da ist kein Lego Portal dabei.
Wobei, das war ja gar nicht Lego Portal, das war ja Lego, da war ja noch mehr drin als Portal.
Ah, das Bauch, das nickt für mich.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, das glaube ich nicht mein.
Ach so Easykiller, ich hatte es nur noch im Hinterkopf, dass die irgendwie über Payday 2 übelsten Cellout gestartet haben.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Getting Over It, bloß von links nach rechts.
Nee, das muss nicht sein.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an Getting Over It, oder aktuell spielen sie auf Twitch alle Jump King.
Schonmal guter Name.
Ruckelt das? Nee, ich glaube die Aufnahme von dem Typ ruckelt einfach.
Die Idee ist ganz gut.
Ja, die sind nicht schlecht.
Da habe ich noch Merchandise von der Gamescom.
Im Schrank. Ich habe mittlerweile so einen kompletten Merchandising Schrank, wo ich einfach alles reinschmeiße.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich damit mache ehrlich gesagt, das ist einfach nur da.
Nee, verkaufen durfte ich das nicht.
Exzellent. Exquisite price.
Wenn ich eigentlich der übelste Kacknupf, wenn ich das nicht gespielt habe.
Okay, der Chat hat es auch nicht gespielt.
Das habe ich mir sogar gekauft auf Steam, habe aber nie gespielt.
Nee, ich habe es nicht gespielt.
Na ja, gut.
Wer will dann auch schon EL-Sachen mit anderen Leuten zusammenspielen?
Oh, da brauchst du dann erstmal deine 300 Stunden, bis du reingekommen bist.
Ich glaube, wenn man da jetzt einsteigt, hast du echt was zu tun, bis du da aufgeholt hast.
Doch wenn du da einsteigst, kriegst du erstmal sowas von auf den Sack.
Oh, ich habe schon alles gedacht, das ist 76.
Das sieht halt aus wie ein Game von 2005, oder?
Hab ich noch nie von gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist glaube ich nicht so meins.
Okay, Plekki, habe ich schon nie gehört, das sagt mir gar nichts.
Nassiv.
XCOM, ja das ist nice.
Ich habe den 2er aber nicht gespielt.
Hawaii sagt hallo, hi.
Aber dem Namen kann ich bloß sagen.
Das lohnt sich, ja das lohnt sich.
Da hat man auch lange Spaß dran.
Man muss halt ehrlich sagen, nach dem ersten Drittel vom Game, wenn man nicht total vergimt, skillt und auch ein bisschen auf sein Equipment guckt, ist man echt krass OP.
Also wenn man nicht total kacke skillt und ein bisschen guckt, was man noch anzieht und vielleicht ein bisschen auf die Umgebung achtet, ist man nach dem ersten Drittel des Games so übelst OP, dass man eigentlich nicht verliert.
Ja gut, in WoW werden Leute geschiebt, warum nicht in Chickens?
Hunderte Stunden über die Weihnachtsferien.
Äh, kein Bock auf ein neues Far Cry.
Drei und vier in dem Style hat mir gereicht, ich brauch nicht noch eins.
Ja gut, das ist auch nicht schwierig.
Sag mal, sag mal Leute, Leute mal, dumme Frage, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Konnte man im alten Far Cry auch schon durch die Wände die Gegner sehen?
Konnte man im Dreier schon Leute durch die Wände sehen, wenn man die gespottet hat mit dem Fernklasse?
Genau, ja.
Oder wenn man drauf gezielt hat, stimmt, stimmt, ja.
Das hab ich mir auch mal gekauft, voll das Spiel, das, das soll wirklich nicht schlecht sein.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist sehr spezifisch, aber es ist auch sehr Spaß und das ist einer der Levels in diesem Spiel.
Und es gibt viele mehr, und es ist einfach super.
Das Gefühl des Humors hier ist auch top-notch und es ist eines der seltenen Spiele, die man genießen kann, egal wie alt man ist.
Ein Hat in Zeit ist auf Sale für £11,49 oder $14,99.
Ja gut, das hatten wir ja schon öfters genug, das haben wir schon oft genug.
Und ob das jetzt das beste Spiel aller Zeiten ist, kann man sich nicht überschreiten, das ist auf jeden Fall kein schlechtes Game.
Meinung zur Gothic Serie, beste.
Vor allem das Voice Acting im ersten Gothic, Alter.
Wobei ich nur Gothic 1 und 2 gespielt hab.
Das 3er hab ich gar nicht gespielt und die Nachfolger, die später gekommen sind, hab ich auch nicht mehr gespielt.
Hast du den Teaser gespielt? Nein, aber ich hab mir den Let's Play angeguckt von dem Teaser.
Das ist ja nicht mal ein Teaser, das ist ja quasi ein Appetit haben, ob die Leute Lust haben, das zu spielen, ob sie es überhaupt entwickeln sollen.
Aber das, was ich gesehen habe, hat mit dem originalen Gothic jetzt relativ wenig am Hut.
Aber das ist ja nicht mal ein Teaser, das ist ja quasi ein Appetit haben, ob die Leute Lust haben, das zu spielen, ob sie es überhaupt entwickeln sollen.
Fable hab ich nicht groß gespielt, kann ich nix zu sagen.
Ich hab Fable 1 mal gespielt, vor Ewigkeiten, das ist ja auch schon lange.
Gucken wir mal, das raus ist 2004, ja das ist schon uralt. Aber auch nie wirklich weit und nie durch, kann ich nix groß zu sagen.
So Leute, wir gucken jetzt noch einen Battlefield Top Play ist, dann muss ich weg.
Für der Zeit, der Dominator 666 ist am Start.
Aber klar, Miami hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Wirklich treffen du da nicht, oder?
Okay, das ist halt Glück.
All die Musik dabei.
Das war schon ein cooler Streak, das war ein cooler Streak, vor allem, weil alles Headshots.
Die Map hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Sniper Kills in 3 und 4 hat sich halt cool angeführt.
Striker, das müsste jetzt Battlefield 4 sein.
Oh, das war natürlich ein nicer Treffer.
Das hier, also wenn man nicht wüsste, dass es Battlefield 4 ist, so rein von der Karte und hier von dem Launcher könnte es Bad Company 2 sein.
Ist es aber nicht, aber rein von der Map her, wie sie aussieht und der Launcher könnte es Bad Company 2 sein.
Ach, das war die Map.
Da hat er Glück gehabt, dass er rein gerannt ist.
War quasi ein Roadkill.
Okay, das ist jetzt wirklich gewollt.
Ich mein, klar, da muss immer noch Glück haben, dass der Typ da rein fliegt, aber...
PS4!
Oder ist das sogar PS3?
Das ist so hässlich, das könnte sogar PS3 sein.
Der stellt sich jetzt drauf und fliegt über die Map, oder was?
Ja? Und?
Und? Schießt jetzt den Heli ab?
Das ist gestellt! Das ist gestellt!
Das ist gestellt! Äh, der schießt jetzt den Heli ab mit dem Baumstamm, hä?
Das ist gestellt!
100%! Das ist setup!
Das ist setup!
Es ist cool, aber es ist auf jeden Fall setup.
Ja, dass es funktioniert, dass es schon da ist.
Okay, das ist echt Glück.
Das ist wirklich sehr glücklich.
Weil der schießt einfach random auf den Panzer und trifft noch nicht mal gut und dann fliegt ihm der Heli rein.
Also sehr glücklich.
Oh, noch nicht mal face! Ass!
Erstmal reparieren, wieder hochfliegen, reparieren.
Das ist sehr knapp.
Das ist sehr knapp, sehr knapp.
Gag-Age, die hier!
Die sitzen auch den ganzen Tag da oben, hä?
Oh, das war gut.
Wieder braindead Gegner.
Ah, das hat schon weggesprayt. Aber die Gegner sind wieder komplett hier an Tod.
Also so pixelig wie das ist, würde ich die Gegner gar nicht erkennen.
Aber Konsol-Grafx.
Ja, die sind wirklich clueless.
Aber aktuell sehe ich noch nicht mal Enemys.
Die checken jetzt, VTF, die Gegner. Die kapieren ja gar nichts.
Das ist nicht so, als hätte er hier den über krassen Sniper-Skill am Start.
Aber der war gut.
Die Gegner sind so fail. Die Gegner sind so dumm.
Sag mal, was ist mit denen denn los? Haben sie in das Hirn raus operiert oder was?
Kopf aus, Hirn raus.
Oh Gott, die Gegner, Alter.
So Leute, ich muss weg. Weihnachtspflichten erfüllen.
Wir sehen uns. Ich habe immer noch Urlaub bis nächstes Jahr.
Also macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Schremen.
Danke für die Subs. Ich guck mal, dass ich nichts vergessen habe vorzulesen.
Den haben wir hier noch.
Musenik. Ich glaube, den habe ich vorgelesen. Danke für den Sub.
Saboteur R habe ich glaube ich vergessen. Aber das war gestern schon.
Ok, danke schön Leute. Wunderbar. Schön, dass ihr da gewesen seid.
Du bist der Meinung, dass der Baumstamm kein Setup war.
Kann auch einfach nur mega Glück gewesen sein, dass der Typ gerade da am Helispawn rumgewurstet ist.
Ja, kann auch sein. Das sah halt schon verdächtig nach Setup aus.
Leute, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. See you. Bis dann.